what do you think inspires more violence
saying listen
okay some of them are great people but
some some of them
are rapists right they're bringing crime
we need to know who's in here which is
very similar to the rhetoric of obama or
someone saying
hey this president exterminates mexicans
isn't that more likely to inspire a
brown person to go and say oh they're
going to exterminate me
they mean what they say he mean what he
say
i want to hear what you think the worst
uh uh i guess sort of
worst fake news stories worst misleading
facts the
biggest outright lies regarding firearms
firearm ownership
uh in recent uh recent days so uh here
are the top five that we've compiled for
you in the aftermath obviously of these
shootings the left-wing media they
churn out fake news faster than
something that turns things out really
quickly
everyone's been jumping on this
bandwagon for the moral high ground even
the president of mexico has been
demanding more gun control not in mexico
mind you
but here in the united states oh my gosh
that's rich
the president of mexico which by the way
earned him a face-to-face state visit
from president trump oh hey don't get
tough with me record about the bite i'll
kick your butt
hey hey hey you got it back to the next
good boy
boy how about your chips
hey that's right i'm back down with you
come on cry come on next year boy cry
for me
come on andy garcia cry for me come on
apocalypse don't cry for me
come on cry for me come on
[Music]
i can tell by the reaction of the studio
that no one here saw the great santini
we're going to help you
wade through one of my favorite films
robert duvall look it up
uh five lies uh from the last week so
fifth lie
uh this is one that we've heard a lot
that trump this is one that's been
parroted and it really bothers me i even
talked about it in the cell phone upload
video people saying oh i hear you're
saying this but where's the source
all right i've got it for you now
humdrum 84.
okay just so you know i've heard
this is a lie you've heard it from me
that president trump made it easier for
the mentally ill
to purchase guns despite these recent
references and talk
about mental health donald trump
actually cancelled an obama era safety
rule that tried to prevent mental
people from acquiring guns in the first
place
one of the only major actions that
president trump has taken on gun control
is to block an obama-era rule
that uh made it harder for the mentally
ill to have access to guns
the only thing worse than your fake news
is your fake nose that was like janet
jackson
um so here's the truth president trump
reversed an obama administration rule
that stripped second amendment rights
from all senior citizens who had been
declared incompetent to manage their
pension
or disability payments or drive this is
important there are already laws in the
book that prevent crazies from buying
guns
think about how scary this is just
because a senior might need help
managing their
money right does that mean they should
lose their right to basic self-defense
yeah it's a little weird even even
the aclu had a real problem with this
law and supported president trump in
reversing this yeah another lie that
we've heard this is one you've heard a
lot and it just drives me crazy anyone
who's owned this is one thing we've
talked about hashtag gift a gun
these lies go away once someone has ever
purchased a firearm yeah
once they understand the limitations on
purchasing a firearm once they
understand what you can and cannot
uh procure in this country they go oh oh
i now understand that these people are
lying so one that they use
constantly is a this word play the ak-47
style rifle was used in these shootings
hey police say that the ak-47 style
rifle that patrick curtis used in the el
paso attack was bought
legally went into the walmart first to
eat before going back to his car
taking out an ak-47 style assault rifle
and firing it's not a firearm it's more
of a bullet
stylist the el paso shooter used a wasr
a10 okay now
unlike the ak-47 there's no select fire
this is a semi-automatic weapon you're a
competitive shooter bill you see this
all the time they try to conflate
automatic semi-automatic
and they just say ak-47 style well i
haven't do you mean because it looks
like it
sometimes they're not even the same
caliber you mean for example i mean you
have a ar5 i have an
ar-15 and a 22 platform it's not even
the same caliber as most people are
referring to
by the way we're talking about the
actual ak-47 caliber fired uh
from a semi-automatic rifle let's
compare it to a very common hunting
round the 30.6 do we have this right
here
can we show it actual size yeah look at
that wow
so there you have it 30.6 on the right
is the ak-47 right the round so this
idea that it's
this death round this happened with the
the ar-15 when they try to complete it
with
m16 right people think it's this laser
machine of death no it's actually not
any kind of a semi-automatic hunting
rifle that has some sort of a detachable
magazine could be
far more deadly most people just aren't
necessarily afraid of them because they
have wood
and steel as opposed to polymer it's the
wood it really does the trick
all right uh third letter i have a real
problem let's just go to this right now
actually
is uh this be this whole this entire how
much of this chart or digital
pamphlet this goes to me in the hall of
fame uh
as far as digital pamphlets please do
not rape
passed out in cologne germany look at
this this is keep this up here
this whole bbc digital chart pamphlet it
says
that the uh ar-15 can be fired
1200 times up to 1200 rounds will be
fired per minute as
an m16 a fully automatic which is just
an ar that's fully automatic
950. those are numbers and the ak-47 by
the way is also a semi-automatic so
basically guns one through four
technically not a revolver but all of
those
firearms outside of the m16 would be
semi-automatic but for some reason one
fire is 50 and one fires 1200
per minute this just highlights the fact
that the media doesn't even care to do
basic research they
they're not looking over their shoulder
for any kind of accountability right no
who's who's there to hold them
accountable nobody they just pull it out
and don't say anything about it and this
is important
this just this one is so obvious that
we're laughing at it but it just happens
to be the one where they were caught
and you see how they behaved when they
were cut they don't issue you know we're
talking about journalistic integrity
right they talk about fake news and the
importance of legitimate news outlets
like government-funded bbc retraction
correction
now we're just going to remove the what
is it does that average out to 90
bullets per second what's 1200 you're
hearing i cheat off your test not a math
agent
no nails no railroads no maps not a
match
by the way hit the notification bell if
you haven't already because apparently
subscriptions don't mean a whole lot and
youtube's not going to be a fan of this
one
uh join my club lot of credit.com club
you get the entire blaze catalog the
daily show of course and
do subscribe on itunes and uh uh like us
write us their crowded bits there's a
channel on youtube if you guys want to
watch the short uh sketches and clips a
lot of them have to feature half asian
bill richmond all right here's the
second worst lie i think we have to get
going we have dan crenshaw i think
waiting
um this one really bothered me you heard
this all over the news that we didn't
have enough info about the dayton
shooter right this was one
i've watched cnn for six hours the day
of the day i'm shooting we were there we
were there doing change my mind all
morning i was watching it
uh why well it turned out to be a
radical leftist who called the antifa
fire bomber a martyr
okay uh to give you a more specific
example response to an activist tweet
about uh what to do if trump wouldn't
leave the white house the dayton shooter
responded arm
train and prepare and here's the thing
we knew this was a radicalized
socialist far leftist elizabeth warren
supporter when the media could no longer
pretend that the shooter's background
and ideology were completely unknown
but they pretended as though it was
irrelevant at that point
wow so for proof here's the dnc pool boy
in chief chris cuomo
taking the moral high ground in covering
the dayton shooting
i don't talk about who these killers are
i don't want to get into their biography
they are they are irrelevant in terms of
why they did this and who helped them
we don't want to get into their mode
over their background really mr dnc
pool boy in chief here's the easy part
a white nationalist coward who kills
people to motivate a political cause
is no different than an isis coward
doing the same thing
they are both terrorists wow and you
know it
when it comes to el paso i guess we're a
little bit murky in the dnc rule book
so that's how he covers dayton and then
el paso
so wait
he's a piece of right is that yeah is
that about right with chris cuomo this
brings us to lie number one
that the el paso shooter this has been
spread everywhere what we used to joke
about people would say oh you're picking
a small
you see this with leftist youtubers all
the time and say oh you pick a small
percentage of social justice workers
that's not the left the real left right
most liberals
we want to talk about the issues and
taxes we're not offended by everything
we don't think everything's racist
really the number one lie that i saw was
that the el paso shooter was inspired by
trump's
calling for the extermination latinos
that it was racist right
and by the way this is these are quotes
on msnbc nicole wallace claims that
president trump actually called for the
extermination of latinos
you don't have a president as you said
talking about exterminating
right latinos to be fair uh we actually
do have the
clip of president trump's infamous
speech about exterminating latinos
that was brought courtesy of the bbc no
one
[Laughter]
called her on it on the panel but then
she admitted on twitter later on that
she misspoke
and then instead of other accusations of
racism at the president
we talk about this oh the rhetoric right
hold on a second um
if you if all of us believed that there
was someone out there right now in the
united states
who were who's actively exterminating
for example an actual nazi
yeah actually exterminating jews
actually exterminating mexicans right
a reasonable response if this person was
committing an act of extermination
would be violence if that were the case
so let me ask you what do you think
inspires more violence saying
listen okay some of them are great
people but some
some of them are rapists right they're
bringing crime we need to know who's in
here which is very similar to the
rhetoric of obama or someone saying
hey this president exterminates mexicans
isn't that more likely to inspire a
brown person to go and say oh they're
going to exterminate me
they mean what they say he mean what
he's saying
according to his own manifesto what we
think is his manifesto right now because
apparently he was posted by someone else
but let's go with the idea that it's
a manifesto um the shooter explicitly
stated that he wasn't motivated by trump
we've already dealt with dayton who was
a radical leftist so let's deal with
this idea that this guy was a white
supremacist slash conservative because
they want you to believe two are
interchangeable just like they want you
to believe that donald trump wants to
exterminate mexicans i hate all the
things
notice the general stuff in the el paso
manifesto that's linked to trump or fox
news
could just as easily be linked to almost
any politician
by these standards we could definitely
say that obama inspired the manifesto
let me read a quote that way i can give
my brain time to recover
he said the american people are
welcoming and generous people but those
who enter our country illegally and
those who employ them disrespect the
rule of law and because we live in an
age where terrorists are challenging our
borders we cannot allow people to pour
into the united states undetected
undocumented and unchecked
americans are right to demand better
border security and better enforcement
of the
immigration laws racist we could say
that inspires
i mean you can look at the floor's uh
consent policy under clinton back to wh
while we're talking about people in
cages and you could say he inspired the
manifesto
and sure there are clear sort of right
wing aspects of the ideology but a large
part of the manifesto people don't talk
about this
was devoted to neo-environmentalism the
the type that we had ranted about by
uh ocasio-corotez he even quoted the
lorax as inspiration
wow this is a crazy person who was
inspired to mass murder people by a
children's film
and it wasn't even pixar
and here's something just as important
this is general broad stroke where they
say donald trump because donald trump
says we need to close the borders as
everyone has but the very specific
content that you see that's unique to
the manifesto
is is like richard spencer-esque white
nationalist socialist
stuff it's pushing for universal
healthcare universal basic income but we
can only afford it if we get rid of
immigrants
that's what he was talking about this is
this is what's so alarming to me if you
read it when people say oh you think
nazis are socialists they were
nationalists national socialist
party right same thing neo-nazis are
just socialists who watched a little too
many edward furlong films okay
they think if we just got rid of brown
people if we just got rid of immigrants
we could have
socialized everything that's not
conservative at all and one thing
one thing and we have to go on this it
really pissed me off did you see the
chris cuomo tweet we were saying
actually uh if you look at uh was he
talking was scalia i think he said if
you look at scalia he actually
was the one who rewrote the constitution
inserted in the constitution
the right to private firearm ownership
so originalists you should know that
hold on a second
again that wording do we have a
different constitution now
no what it was was an interpretation of
the original intent from the
constitution which is crystal clear when
you look at all the founding documents
in tandem together you probably know
this more than anyone but i have to
get moving on this here go back to hella
versus dc this is something that they
don't tell you okay heller versus dc is
that case where you look at the
dissenting opinions yeah we're talking
about scalia
the decision thank god said of course
private citizens have the right to own
firearms
so when you look at the dissenting
opinions in that case
it wasn't oh we should get rid of fully
automatic weapons
it wasn't background checks it wasn't
gun show loophole
it was when you have people like
ginsburg saying
private citizens have no right to own a
firearm
whatsoever yeah that was the only legal
argument made
you can read it heller versus dc search
it right now but chris cuomo won't say
that why because he knows that that is
just as unpalatable
to you as the idea of people going out
there with panzers down the street right
they say most
americans support reasonable gun control
and then they quote hello versus dc hall
second do they consider reasonable gun
control
you can't own any firearms at all
because that's what the leftist judges
said and to give you an idea when you
look at this unholy amalgamation of
big tech and and media and the
government
i was working with google right google
actually came to me youtube they came to
me and told me hey
start running some ads on youtube right
start running your videos as ads on
youtube
and i said well i don't know what they
said no let us help you start a campaign
one of the videos was
a video that we did about the gun show
loophole so i started running this as an
ad and she said oh wow this is
interesting maybe i'll watch this when
we're done
by the way i have all these emails in
case anyone's questions so you can keep
yeah
interesting well you know i don't really
know i haven't really fired a gun i said
oh you've never shot a gun [ __ ] no no i
said
you ever owned one she said no no never
owned a gun anyone in your family ever
owned a gun
no no no i said oh where do you work she
worked in i think product management or
an ad development you know one of those
made up terms and i said oh yeah
so do you know anyone who owns a firearm
she said
no it's really not that kind of place no
one knows so you don't know
anybody who has ever owned or shot a
firearm the answer was no
and these people are meeting with
representatives to determine firearm
policy which by the way
includes the idea the dissenting opinion
that you have no
right to own a firearm whatsoever think
about that for a second
think about those people being in
control of your aspect of this aspect of
your god-given right to
self-preservation and if it doesn't send
chills down your spine then
maybe caitlyn jenner will hey there if
you like this video this is the part
where i would usually tell you to
subscribe but
i can't do it anymore i'm going to tell
you to subscribe and then youtube is
going to decide that
we can't reach you even though you
subscribe to this channel and then i'll
say hit the notification bell
and then the notification bell won't
even be there anymore
i don't know what to say more than
likely you'll find my face in a milk
carton but do what you can to stop it
it's just it's just it probably won't do
much